good day everyone this is Paul and you
are watching the Lang focused Channel
and today we're going to talk about some
interesting stuff we're going to talk
about the difference between a language
and a dialect now what is the difference
all over the world there are people who
speak closely related forms of
communication sometimes they are called
different languages sometimes they are
called dialects of one language so how
do we decide which one they are
sometimes there's some disagreement
about which one a particular form of
communication is is it a dialect or is
it a separate language the dialect
really means a variety of speech that
differs somewhat from another variety of
speech of that same language it could
differ in grammar to differ in phonology
or pronunciation it could differ in
vocabulary could differ and all of those
maybe sometimes those dialects are based
in different regions there are regional
varieties of a language sometimes they
are ethnic varieties of a language for
example maybe there are two ethnic
groups living in a city but historically
they've lived separate and not really
interacted with each other because of
racism or whatever and they've developed
separate dialect because of that
separation so they're almost living in
two worlds within the same city that
kind of thing so it's almost like a
different regional dialect inside your
your own town if you know what I mean
now within every language there is some
degree of variety some degree of
difference there are some different
spoken varieties of every language so
how do we decide if it's close enough to
the language to be considered a dialect
and when is it not well one of the main
criteria that is most often used is
mutual intelligibility that means the
speakers of those two different
varieties of the language can understand
each other fully or almost fully
understand each other we would say
they're mutually intelligible in that
case so according to this definition
simply if you can understand each other
you can understand them you can make
yourself understood to them then you are
speaking the same language and if even
if there's some degree of difference in
grammar or phonology or vocabulary
those are dialectal differences because
you can
and each other the languages are close
enough that they are considered the same
language according to that definition
now the problem with this definition is
that sometimes speakers of what is
considered to be one language often
can't understand each other like for
example often I can't understand people
who speak a Scottish dialect of English
we're not when I select some daily you
know a person doing that when that's all
good [ __ ] can you see it even you
finally get the boy Steve Matic a quote
you see by enough to glasses often I
can't understand people who speak a
Scottish dialect of English or sometimes
an Australian dialect of English if they
come from like the deep countryside of
Australia sometimes I can't understand
them and this is especially true if I
overhear two of those people speaking
together I hear them speaking with each
other not directly to me
then they'll speak in their full-on
different accent different dialect and
sometimes I can't understand so are we
speaking a different language because
it's not mutually intelligible so that's
kind of the difficult point of this
definition sometimes I can't understand
other speakers of English but I think
it's the same language and so today so
what's going on there so that brings me
to another criteria of what would make
two spoken varieties just dialects of
one language and that is this both of
those varieties use the same written
standard variety of language these the
same written standard the same written
language even though the spoken language
may differ somewhat so that would
explain why I speak English and a
Scottish person speaks English even if
there may be some trouble communicating
we both use the same written language we
both write in the same way we read the
same books and then when we speak to
each other we can adapt our speech to
make it a little bit more like the
written standard now that's why we can
communicate even though I can't really
understand their variety of English when
they speak the piriform when they speak
it with each other I don't really know
what to sang a lot of the time but when
they speak to me they kind of use book
English a little bit literary English
they use more of the written standard
and mix it in with their natural dialect
to make it understandable to me
and I think I do the same unconsciously
that's what makes us speakers of the
same language the fact
we we blend our variety of speech with
that same written standard and that's
what helps us to communicate across
dialects now the one weakness in this
criterion is that there are people who
can't really speak the standard language
that well so that's true in English you
have some people who are uneducated
maybe they're poor maybe high school
dropouts maybe they the type of people
who just don't really care about
studying or speaking properly they don't
really know the standard language they
might understand it but they can't speak
like that so are those speakers of the
same language even though they don't
really know how to use the standard
written language properly so that's kind
of the trouble with with that criterion
but so far that's the best criterion
that I've found to explain what is a
dialect and what's a language that
written common standard language now as
with all things in life the situation
gets messy when we bring politics into
it because sometimes we have we have two
varieties of language that are almost
exactly the same but they have two
different names in two different
countries or they're spoken by two
different ethnic groups and they both
claim that language as their own so they
call it by different names and it causes
a lot of weird confusion so I've I think
it's like that in the former Yugoslavia
for some of the languages there there
are people who just don't want to be
associated with the other people so they
they call the language by the name of
their own ethnic group even though it's
the same as the language of another
ethnic group basically so even though
the standard written language might be
pretty much the same might be slightly
different but it's pretty much the same
and the spoken language is pretty much
the same maybe with some variation but
they're mutually intelligible even the
standard written language is mutually
intelligible but they call it a
different language because of whack-ass
politics I don't like politics I'm not a
political person I'm more interested in
cultures and in people so I don't really
by that definition I don't like it when
people say we speak a different language
because we have a different ethnic group
a different nationality we're going to
call this language ours it's not yours
its ours
I don't really like that kind of
territorial claiming of languages so I
don't by this definition I think if you
can speak together with each other and
it's mutually intelligible you can read
the same books then in my opinion you're
speaking the same language I don't
really buy the political
definition of what's the language and
what's a dialect so basically my
definition of a dialect is that it's
mutually comprehensible with another
variety of language so if you can
communicate with them they understand
you you understand them and you can use
the written language elements of the
written language to make yourself even
more understood then I think you are
speaking dialects of the same language I
hope that is helpful I hope that gives
you some something to think about leave
your comments down below tell me if you
agree with my opinion on this matter
alright this is Paul signing off see ya